my friend says hey my sister brought
back all these free posters you want
some right now why would the Soviet
Union give away free propaganda posters
too naive stupid you know
Westerners so I remember an imagined
life choosing one of Lenin and thinking
well that sort of looks okay and I put
it up I was living off-campus in my room
my mom and dad came to visit and my
father looked at it and he looked at me
and he said Eric could I speak with you
for a minute and it suddenly dawned on
me my father said I want to ask you a
favor would you take that down and it
was as if the scales fell from my eyes
and I realized what what has happened to
me I mean they're 100 other examples but
those are the two moments that I
remember suddenly coming to myself and
thinking how is it possible that I
thought it was okay to do that when my
father raised me to despise communism
you know the way souls and eason and
Buckley despised communism let's back up
a little bit further you described sort
of the immigrant family and you went
into college somewhat conservative do
you remember the moments where that
started breaking up yeah yeah where the
ideas were really infecting you yeah can
you talk I've actually I'll never forget
it and I and I in fact I have just
finished writing like the memoir of my
life that takes me up to my twenty-fifth
birthday in this dramatic conversion
dream and in there I write about these
two things basically first of all I was
hanging out with a lot of different
people but the general Emilia was
secular humanist liberal no question
about it and I was you know by being
raised the way I was I kind of bumped
into this like what's this I didn't know
that oh you can't say oriental you have
to say Asian you can't say like suddenly
I was getting all of these things that
oh you can't do that you can't do this
now it's like oh so I was raised by
people who didn't know this stuff but
now MIT Yale where everybody knows
everything these are the future leaders
and and I'm just gonna go along with
them so you're picking this stuff up but
I remember two instances this is classic
I
I was we had a vote you could this is
nothing has changed in all these years
we were having a vote whether our class
funds should divest from corporations
that were involved in South Africa right
because it was right before a part that
I broke up and everything like that and
and what I find interesting is that
there was only one way to vote in other
words it wasn't like let's actually
think about this it was kind of the woke
thing like are you gonna say how Hitler
or not you're gonna take a knee or not
we're not giving you choices you know
what you need to do are you gonna do it
here's your opportunity to do it and to
show solidarity so everybody voted the
right way except a friend of mine who
oddly enough is a Democrat but he was an
economics major and he said no I don't
actually think it's gonna help the
people of South Africa we do though so
he voted ok a different way but here's
the key then make stay in the dining
hall a very dear friend of mine comes up
to me who was involved in this voting
process and he says hey your buddy Chris
you know he voted no and I'll never
forget it's as if my whole upbringing
you know came to me and I thought this
is America you mean you looked at his
vote and you have you dare to tell me
that he voted the wrong way as though it
wasn't an actual election that's what
they do in Red China like I remember
being chilled just being horrified not
too long after that I had an experience
where a friend of mine sister and I
imagine this is still Reagan so a friend
of mine sister went to the Soviet Union
this is like all the you know the woke
Manhattan elites send their kids to
whatever schools and there's a semester
in Moscow to study economics and she
brought back a ton of propaganda posters
so my friend says hey my sister brought
back all these free posters you want
some right now why would the Soviet
Union give away free propaganda posters
too naive stupid you know Westerners so
I remember an imagined life choosing one
of Lenin and thinking well that that
sort of looks okay and I put it up I was
living off campus in my room my mom and
dad came to visit and my father looked
at it and he looked at me and he said
Eric could I can I speak with you
for a minute and it suddenly dawned on
me my father said I want to ask you a
favor
would you take that down and it was as
if the scales fell from my eyes and I
realized what what has happened to me I
mean there are hundred other examples
but those are the two moments that I
remember suddenly coming to myself and
thinking how is it possible that I
thought it was okay to do that when my
father raised me to despise communism
you know the way Souls and eats inand
Buckley despised communism so what's
interesting about this to me there's a
couple things but particularly is that
if you listen to sort of mainstream
media now this this idea of the woke
college thing people think it's it's a
it's an idea of the last five years or
something yeah it's just this last
millennial generation that's going
through it but what years were you in
college I was I was there I graduated in
84 but it was in full swing it was in
full swing in the early 80s and look
let's be honest this stuff started at
least in 1968 I mean it's only a matter
of the trickle-down effect when did it
get to the mainstream and the fact of
the matter is that Yale and places like
that are they're the worst offenders of
this kind of stuff I if I ever had money
I wouldn't give them money they are the
absolute worst offenders they have been
leading the charge with this kind of
stuff so I saw this you know maybe
earlier than a lot of other people did
but it was it was an absolute full force
so I feel like we got to talk about that
dream a little bit because you told me
you had a dream and it changed your life
but we need to know some details on this
thing yeah well I always tell people to
go to my website to watch the video of
the dream because it's very hard takes I
will try because I like you I will try
very hard to be more sublime I wasn't
the first question it's tricky stuff
I'll tell you why and this is I wrote a
whole book on miracles and sometimes
what makes a miracle dramatic is the
context right in other words if God is
speaking to someone it may make sense to
that person because they bring a whole
bunch of context to that situation and
it wouldn't mean anything to anyone else
in my case if you had you know put a gun
to my
at age 24 and said who are you you know
in like in a dream or in a fairytale in
your core who are you I would have you
know I don't think I could have come up
with it but but the most basic elements
if they were let's say three of who who
I was at that point were the Greek
immigrant upbringing was at the at the
center of my life there's no question
and the second thing was that for all of
my you know teen years or childhood or
whatever I I was fishing right over
there when I wasn't watching TV when I
wasn't watching you know Sanford and Son
and the Dean Martin roasts I was I was
fishing and that's just what I did so I
never got in trouble I studied I watched
TV and I did a lot of fishing so that
was a big part of me but also weird
connection is that my father whenever he
saw because all Greeks are evangelists
for being Greek you know their number
one hobby is being Greek and so my
father any time he saw a fish a chrome
fish on the back of a car on the 70s you
know he would say you see that fish that
comes from the Greek word because the
early Christians couldn't use the sign
of the Cross they had they used the
symbol of the fish because the Greek
word for fish the ancient word is egg
this that's where we get exile adjust
right and it's this the words it's an
acronym isus Christ us they asked Eman
Sathya it spells Jesus Christ the Son of
God our Savior and so they used the
secret symbol of the fish and my father
says to me in Danbury Connecticut on the
highway see that fish it's a Greek word
he gets all excited about the fact that
it's Greek now I'm being a little unfair
I think he was aware of the Christian
element but he was very excited that the
fish you know is a Greek it's a Greek
word so in any event the third part of
me if you're gonna say there's fishing
there's the Greek thing the third part
of me was what I call the life of the
mind from age 16 to 24 I'm trying to
figure out the meaning of life I'm
trying to figure out who am i why am I
here and whenever i was reading the
literature that I was reading in college
I wasn't reading it the way most people
read it I was trying to figure out what
is the clue to humanity who are we and
what and it's you know good art that's
what it does it helps you understand
what does it mean to be human and so on
so I was trying to puzzle this out and I
remember that at some point just after
graduating and getting you know the woke
memo that Christianity is too parochial
the Bible it's just a bunch of
right-wing you know right bigots but but
if there's any religion
it probably combines all religions and
it's probably more like a new-age
life-force or something like that and I
came up with this idea in my own that
you know what it's sort of like Freud's
idea of the soul right where you have
the conscious mind and then you have the
unconscious below the conscious mind and
I kind of brought in a little young this
is supposed to sound pretentious I was
an undergraduate right so I have yeah I
had this idea that maybe the goal of
life is that the ice on the lake is is
the conscious mind and that the water
beneath it is the unconscious or what
Jung calls the collective unconscious
which is this God force or something
like that and I thought maybe that's
what all religions are getting at so the
goal of life is to drill through the ice
so that you have an emotionally healthy
connection between the conscious mind
and the collective unconscious or God or
whatever it is now what does that mean
practically bubkis nothing of course it
just means like I figured that out I got
it all religions say the same thing and
I'm gonna move on with my life if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell